le printemps de bourges ce n'est pas
seulement celui de la météo c'est aussi
un festival qui depuis cinq ans réunit
des chanteurs de différents genres des
grands noms comme julien clerc mais
aussi des marginaux et des débutants
cette manifestation est surtout
l'occasion de faire le point sur les
différents courants de la chanson
française un reportage de jean jacques
lachance on aime le non-dit les non
lieux et les personnages ambigus ce que
les gens viennent entendre au fond c'est
ce que je ne dis pas dixit bernard la
ville vit avec qui commençait samedi
dernier ce cinquième printemps de
bourges qui continuent bon an mal an
malgré l'absence de subvention du
ministère de la culture
du banc
une armée
tous les jours et jusqu'à dimanche
prochain les spectacles clac en six
lieux différents langis three blanche
mise en scène et interprétée par les
mirabelles raconte la vie de quatre
blanchisseuse c'est cocasse pathétique
et émouvant
un festival éclectique donc qui innové
en ouvrant les portes de la cathédrale à
l'ascension
à propos de chansons le magazine que
choisir publie un grand dossier dans son
numéro d'avril intitulé le disque est
rayé et où il est dit qu on entend
toujours les mêmes à la radio et la
télévision
jacques bertin qui signait ici ses
livres est bien d'accord là dessus en
revanche julien clerc estime que tout
cela est exagéré ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que il arrive assez souvent aussi
que les médias soient la traîne derrière
le public alors là les dernières années
à raison comme bernard l'aligner comme
michelin etc sont des gens ont été
portés par le public parce que les
médias ont pas su renifler attend le
phénomène qui allait arriver
en tout cas jean claude vannier qui n'a
pas encore atteint le grand public fait
sûrement partie des gens qu'il faut
suivre attentivement tout comme bill
deraime un bluesman de senlis qui n'a
rien à envier aux noirs du d'ipsos
on parle
oh
le
vous
rocher
dans les travées